our next guest California high school
product probably secretly wanted to go
to USC because they're better football
team but shows UCLA where he was known
as an above-average punt returner
drafted by the
team records but let's be honest the
Jags haven't been around that long he
also played for the Oakland Raiders but
we don't talk about that season what he
lacks in height he makes up for hot
takes on running backs please welcome
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
hey doing the amount of money you must
have put up for this place is it's worth
it is it yeah this a rental I didn't buy
this is okay you have money you rent but
you know the thing is is I want to get
back to this audience they deserve this
they do yeah so I want them to feel like
they're here at the Super Bowl even if
you can't be here in the stands there at
the Super Bowl though it's in Atlanta
well they're not at the Super Bowl Yeah
right right right right yeah the Super
Bowls not playing here the field and
everything uh can you tell me what's
going on with Todd Girly's health since
you do yes you do the Rams radio
broadcast as well so what happened with
Gurley in New Orleans
and he's available for the Super Bowl as
what well I think first of all when you
talk about Todd and kind of the stuff
that's going on he just had a bad day
had nothing to do with this house what
is a bad day for a running back what you
saw you know just kind of not the timing
running the ball wasn't there even
though he did score a touchdown but you
know being wide open dropping passes he
just he just wasn't you know I was
trying to go back to my playing days
when you were talking about Jacksonville
so kindly we played the Baltimore Ravens
on Monday night as you know we rarely
got primetime game so it was a big time
for us that year and I fumbled four
times or something and so it was just
sometimes you just you just wake up on
the wrong side of the bed and you have a
bad day and luckily his team was there
to help him out but Todd I mean you
talked about coming off of you know the
little knee issue and going in Dallas
having 14 carries 120 yards he's healthy
he's ready to go he just had a bad day
and kudos to the Saints defense who was
ranked number two against the run they
did a great job stop with the run so I
think it'll be a different challenge
this week for him and I think I'll be
better what do the Patriots do - Jared
Goff uh well the one thing that they
they'll try to do they're gonna try to
disguise coverages they're gonna press
their receivers at the line of scrimmage
trying to knock off their timing but the
other thing they're gonna do is they're
gonna do these stunts where they get
their D in the loop in the middle and
try to get pressure from the inside and
that's what they did against the
Chargers what they did against the
Chiefs and it's the one type of pressure
that no quarterback likes where you can
get hit right off that you know you're
trying to throw down the in the pocket
and someone's flying at you in your face
so Jared golf struggled with
Detroit he struggled with that against
the the Bears I want to say and the
Eagles and so I expect them to do the
same thing but I also look at what the
Rams offer and I've seen other teams in
the playoffs have success with the
Patriots and that's getting pressure up
the middle right and if you get pressure
up the middle you can be Tom Brady no
you beat anybody but if you don't get
pressure right then he's gonna beat you
you know what it's it's uh I broke kind
of broke the game down last week and I'm
gonna give it to you I wasn't going to
but you're such a great guy let me write
it write it down write it down are you
ready for this is the game right so this
is this is important the last two games
the Rams were started slowly where
they've either kicked a field goal on
their first drive or went three and out
they can't do that
they're gonna play the Patriots you have
to score seven on the first two drives
you have to put up 14 quickly to get
them out of this hole pout run the ball
what they've been doing the last couple
of weeks I want to say last four or five
weeks or they've been running Sonia
Michele so for the Rams it's imperative
it's really important significant to win
this game those are big words that I'm
trying to get you to understand right
scoring on your first two possessions
are gonna be it's gonna change the game
or not because if you look at the Chiefs
game it was what 14 nothing if you look
at the Chargers it was 21 7 they're
gonna go down the field they're gonna
eat up a lot of clock running the ball
and dinking and dunking down the field
you got to make sure when you get the
ball that you score and you kind of put
pressure on them ok it sounds easier I
mean no question it sounds easier but
that's why I mean that's why I don't why
it's called the game I don't play so do
you think Belichick watching this show
right now is writing down what you just
said I mean you know first of all let's
be honest I know John McVay so I should
have a head coaching job soon that's all
it takes
I'm just telling you like I said low to
him in an Applebees and I was one yeah
and I got an offer to coach it's crazy
right
oh my god you know Sean McVeigh I said
hello to him why me I'm assuming next
year you know I may be too busy to do
this because I may be interviewing for
jobs you know okay would you give Tony
Romo head coaching job based off of how
often I cast again well to me he's more
he's talking more about all
Tania's defense and wouldn't you make
him a defensive coordinator if he knows
they're back that's what I would think
you'd make him addy corner not a head
coach a head coach has to kind of deal
with egos and he's probably done that
cuz he's worked with tio and a bunch of
other guys days and things like that but
it's just different being a head coach
you got to kind of really be groomed to
do that he'd be crazy to leave the
broadcast booth to become a coach he's
there's no wins and losses on Monday he
feels pretty good when you go to bed
you're always right yeah matter what you
say you could be dead wrong you're
always right yeah that's why when I
heard that I'm going know what he said
he was gonna coach know people say oh
god he's got a coach you know I go no no
no job because you can predict what's
gonna happen and I'm just curious
I'm sorry go ahead I can have that
replaced I was gonna say all this money
you spends around here yeah this chair
that like makes me slide forward I
didn't that's a hot seat that you're on
like it's meant to be uncomfortable
oh is it yeah that's okay well I'm
comfortable but I'm just saying uh let
me see you're joining us on behalf of
the NFL Network Super Bowl coverage and
that'll be on Sunday you can see Maurice
jones-drew it's an eight and a half our
pregame show mode it is it is it's the
first time doing it's I'm a little
nervous for the big day do you have your
suit ready I guess
Oh cuz I do not have to go far you
dressed right now to go to the pregame
show no not at all because it starts at
like in about seven minutes I think if
you know it's ours on a sunny Sunday
hours yeah okay I thought it was like 58
hours you know you're gonna do 9:00 a.m.
Eastern on the NFL Network have you had
a moment where you went
I shouldn't have said that on the air a
bunch of times it's not I want to think
is it that I shouldn't said it it's like
what did I say right like because we
only have so many seconds for you all
that are here TV is all about timing
you know and so there's certain times in
the network I'll have like five minutes
to say something a minute and a half
when you're calling games you only have
15 seconds so you have to kind of
formulate an idea or comment and be able
to spit it out about the game and then
make sure that it sounds somewhat your
children yeah he's Maurice jones-drew
it's always great to see you'd for more
Dan Patrick show to the audience Channel
239 on Direct TV or download the Dan
Patrick show app
[Music]